[Music]
of the andalusian project
um coming at you today with a new video
now i know you're all
quite upset with me because in my last
video which was like two and a half
months ago or so
i informed you that i was going to be
producing more videos
at a much more frequent rate
now
that intention is still there
that said
i know you guys are still upset with me
and uh because i had originally intended
that it would occur immediately after
that video
however something came over me
not an illness by any means thank god
but something else a project that i
wanted to complete
and
i promise you
that i'm going to make it up to you
right now in this video
because for the past two months or so i
have been heavily researching and
writing
an article that has just recently been
released
okay and that article is about the
interpretation of the quran
surah 86 is five through seven uh if
you're not familiar with that it's the
the the controversial
uh versus about um
how the you know the ejected fluid from
the backbone and the ribs
as it's typically translated
so i decided to go out of my way
to research this
to see what classical interpretations
were about this
and compare them to contemporary
translations and contemporary
interpretations
i i examined the
tradition i looked through
lexicons
studied arab
philologists and
yeah
i i went the whole nine yards
and i came to my own conclusions about
the most valid interpretation um in
accordance with the you know muslim
tradition
so
thus far i mean the article's been
been around for about two or three days
now
um thus far the article has been doing
very well it's gained a lot of traction
the opinion has been
accepted and shared among the lay
masses so far
i have very little pushback on it
ex-muslims are particularly upset about
it
because it undermines their whole well
the sign you know the quran is
scientifically inaccurate
claims
but it also undermines a lot of people
who are promoting the scientific
miracles claim so the article is
essentially
around 45 pages
so now you see what i've been doing for
the past two months
and
it has about two figures
like a six-page table
you know explaining all the euphemisms
in the quran related to sex and things
like that
essentially just to give you sort of a
brief on what i'm arguing um i believe
that from between the backbone and the
ribs is a euphemism
for sexual activity between
the mother and father
salve
is
the uh
essentially it should be rendered as the
paternal genitalia
and taraib
is supposed to be rendered as the
maternal
genitalia so the private parts of your
mother and father
and
i go through the quran and the sunnah
the opinions of scholars etc and i find
that those two words were used in
particular uh because they also refer to
adam and eve
now
for those who are interested in
uh further you can just read the paper
uh it's it's gonna be linked in the info
box and also in the comment section uh
both uh to my web page and to the pdf
file so if you guys are interested in
reading it uh please do so let me know
what you think i hope that it's up to
par for your
standards uh yeah so that's what i've
been working on for the past two months
and now i want to get back to videos but
i really had to focus on that and i
really had to get it finished because
this research
took a long time and
a lot of intellectual effort
so
yeah usually it takes me much longer to
finish an article than it does a video
video is pretty easy but when i'm
focused on an article like that's all i
focus on because
i mean that's just how i am generally
with any activity that i'm doing so
um yeah
that's it
so thank you for your patience i do
appreciate you all sticking with me once
again i do apologize for not being here
for such a long time and not giving you
any updates but i didn't want to update
you again without actually producing
something
so
i waited until it was done to make this
video so
yeah there it is that's what i've been
doing for the past two months i hope
that that is sufficient um
and i will now go back to making videos
and i probably won't make another
article like that for quite some time
because that took a lot out of me
and if you haven't noticed i even had i
even you know haven't had time to like
cut my hair or anything so like it grew
out yeah
you know it's funny because some
islamophobes and ex muslims were
spreading this like insult around insult
that i was somehow bald
just because i shaved my head
so so i'm so good at this that even my
hair refutes islamophobes it's amazing
um but don't worry i'm not gonna grow it
out to such an extent that i become you
know everyone's favorite mufti
[Laughter]
i don't even know what i'm drinking
you're a nutty naughty boy
yeah so uh don't worry about that
um but um yeah we'll see how this goes
maybe i'll grow it out further or just
keep it at short length and you know see
what happens maybe i'll just shave it
down again i don't know
but yeah
there it is there's the article i hope
you guys like it uh thank you so much
and uh yeah hope to see you again very
very soon this time and not in another
two months all right